today we're going to be speaking with
heath druzen who's creator and host of
the podcast extremely american produced
in partnership with post-industrial
media and boise state public radio you
can find extremely american everywhere
you get podcasts uh heath it's really
great having you on today i appreciate
it
great to be here thanks
so um you know it certainly since the
trump riots and even before that we've
been covering
militia groups so-called militia groups
for for a long period of time you
covered
the pennsylvania volunteer militia which
is sort of adjacent to some of the other
groups maybe people in my audience are
familiar with can you talk a little bit
about how did you get interested in this
how did you start covering them what are
some of their views how would we
characterize these groups
yeah i mean i've been covering the
militia movement and kind of the the
broader uh far right movement for a
number of years now
what kind of got me started on this
podcast is i started seeing them get a
lot more politically active
kind of come out of the woods come out
of the mountains and be much more
visible in everyday life
uh the pennsylvania volunteers uh they
are an interesting group because they're
led by a guy named christian yangling
and he played a pretty
he played a pretty notable role in
charlottesville in 2017 and your
listeners uh probably recognize that
that was the uh the white supremacist
rally
in charlottesville that also drew in a
lot of militia groups who said they were
there to basically keep the peace
between
right-wing uh protesters and left-wing
counter-protesters some people question
that um so yingling was there um he
actually got sued and
agreed to never come back to
charlottesville with a militia so he's
uh he's been in the news
he's a very sort of colorful character
so i got to know him through that
and
um i had been doing a number of
interviews with him and trying to get in
on his training because i i wanted to
give listeners of my podcast extremely
american i wanted to give them a real
feel for what it's like to be
at a training with a militia what they
do
get there on the gun range with them um
so that's what brought me out there it
took me a while to get their trust but
they eventually
let me come to their monthly training
which is deep in the pennsylvania woods
um kind of out in these rolling
mountains in western pennsylvania this
sort of classic site you would imagine a
militia training happening at yeah so
that's what that's what got me there and
um you know we've spoken to people who
who have i don't want to use the term
infiltrated but who have been sort of
like granted access to different types
of extremists and different different
journalists and reporters take different
approaches in terms of whether
they just remain extraordinarily neutral
in terms of their opinion of what it is
that they're observing or whether they
are sort of engaged in conversations
about their views as to what what these
groups do
what's the dynamic like when you're with
these folks in terms of how they see you
and and sort of what the conversations
are like
yeah i mean so if you if you listen to
the podcast um and especially episode
one with this group what you'll hear is
i let them tell their own story
but you know i i don't i don't just sit
on the sidelines if somebody says
something outlandish i challenge them
yeah so um i'll give you an example you
know christian yingling at one point
he's talking about being between he went
to a trump rally where they were counter
protesters and he was standing with his
guys between the left and right wing
protesters
well he talks about the story about how
he was basically trying to get the
left-wing protesters to back up now
they're in a public park right
he has no authority there he's a private
citizen and he's telling them to back up
and you know i and he's telling them
basically if you don't back up i'm going
to break your leg to one of the guys and
and that's you know that's where i do
step in and i'm like well now hold on
under whose authority do you do that and
so there's back and forth like that um i
do want to let them tell their own story
because i think
that's more interesting for a listener
than me just spouting off but certainly
i'm not going to let something like that
just sort of twist in the wind um so
there's some kind of fun back and forth
about that
about january 6th about donald trump um
so yeah you know i'll challenge people
when i feel like that is appropriate but
i do also want people to to hear their
viewpoint because i think understanding
these groups is much more important than
than slamming them for example just uh
just to sort of feel good at the
individual level you know i've spoken to
a lot of former hate group members
including kkk and some other groups and
the one theme that is present in all of
their stories was
they were sucked in because of a sort of
personal vulnerability of their
situation that came often from sort of
like the prototypical absent or broken
family or or lack of direction from
parents it's like a very similar story
that they all tell
is that
a common backstory in the folks that you
see in the militia groups or is that
different
so i would say there's a little bit a
little bit of yes and no there i've
certainly met people who fit that mold i
think with militia groups though because
most of them um they're they're not
explicitly racist and a lot of them
actually will at least
outwardly reject that i think they have
a bit of broader appeal
um i think i think when you're talking
about like explicitly white supremacist
groups i i think that recruitment's a
little tougher and you really have to to
to try harder with the militia groups
they try to tell they try to have a
bigger tent i guess you can say so what
i do find though is people who are very
disaffected with what's happening in
america um they might be uncomfortable
with a changing country
they might be uncomfortable with
increasing diversity they may not say it
like that but they will talk about
certain things like transgender rights
come up a lot and that makes a lot of
people in this movement uncomfortable
they'll talk about critical race theory
now whether or not that's actually a
real thing in american schools you know
that's obviously something that people
are debating but there is a discomfort
with the changing america that draws
people in and i think certainly donald
trump's rise to power and some of the
things he said made them feel more
empowered than they have and i think
made them feel more comfortable coming
out in the open as opposed to just
training out in the woods
uh is there either is there a notable
undertone of anti-semitism in these
groups
i would actually say no um i am a jewish
reporter um i
you know i i did not feel that directly
um i did speak to one very prominent
jewish member of the three percent
militia in washington state um he
figures prominently in episode three and
we talk a little bit about his
background
now is that to say that there is not a
strain of anti-semitism no i also ran
into some really offensive stuff where
people would talk about they would
compare covet protocols to nazism now is
that directly anti-semitism we can
debate that but it's certainly very
offensive i think to a lot of people
so
i i would say explicitly no you do get
that undercurrent with some people and i
think you do get some sort of explaining
away of stuff
how prominent is the presence of law
enforcement current or former and
military current informer in your
experience in these groups
i run into a lot of ex-military in these
groups um i also run into a lot of
people who kind of are in the uh you
know i wish i would have served kind of
mold um but you do run into a lot of
veterans um you run into some law
enforcement it gets kind of murky
there's there's certainly some law
enforcement that have been supportive um
there's a whole sheriff's movement
called the constitutional sheriff's
movement and they have elected sheriffs
all over the country joe arpaio in
arizona was part of that
and they're very friendly to militias
now you also get law enforcement who are
dead set against them because they see
their anti-government rhetoric is also
anti-law enforcement so it's a very
mixed bag but i would say the veteran
part of it that is a robust part of the
military or the militia movement do the
militia groups get along with each other
or do they see each other as competitors
or they believe they aren't
you know do they have problems with the
ideologies of some of the other groups
so that's a great question um this might
not be surprising but anti-government
movements are not very good at
centralized control so there is a lot of
bickering back and forth and a lot of
infighting um and frankly just some some
honest disagreements where you'll have
groups that absolutely
will disavow um another group including
different three percent groups uh
there's a group in georgia that has a
confederate flag in their logo and some
of the more um some of the some of the
other three percenters in the west you
know they'll look to them and say we
absolutely want nothing to do with those
guys they're racist and we reject them
so it's a mixed bag they do come
together over two things a radical view
of limited government
and pretty much absolutist gun rights
any restriction on gun rights they see
as a red line i would say almost every
militia group agrees on those two things
what is the um or let's see how i can
phrase this
there's the fear among observers of some
of these groups that at some point
they're gonna do like their big thing
you know like the the
you think about jim jones and jonestown
and eventually there was like the mass
suicide of the 950 people in south
america and it was sort of like the
culmination of the entire thing and
there's the fear that some equivalent
not not killing themselves necessarily
but there's the equivalent that they're
building to some kind of big event do
you get the sense that that's the
eventual goal or are they there more of
as like as a constant low-grade
protection again as they see it against
the tyranny and oppression of the
government or whatever the case may be
without planning like some big event
i think what you're seeing is um and
when i get into
in extremely american is the shift away
from that kind of thinking
more to
hey we have this moment when we've got
more mainstream support let's try to
change government from the inside
there's a lot of younger leaders who i
would say are much more politically
savvy than the old guard from the
michigan militia and those kind of
groups and you know they're they're
targeting their local school boards
their library boards they're picking off
state senate and state uh legislature
seats
um so that's not to say we couldn't have
that i mean we've seen it we've seen it
at least twice we saw uh clive and
bundy's ranch where all those militia
guys were pointing weapons at federal
agents that could have gone quickly and
we saw it in oregon where am and bundy
clive and son had an arm stand off of
his own now we could totally see that
again i think a lot of these guys are
much more focused on trying to bring
government to the right
as opposed to you know having an armed
confrontation even though when you ask
them they will admit they are
simultaneously training to fight against
the government and kind of trying to be
a part of it yeah well so that was going
to be my next thing which is you talked
about the presence of military veterans
there's it in hypothetical discussions
about what might happen if one of these
groups really tried something big
there's the reality that eventually they
might be confronting not just police but
if they really wreaked enough havoc the
national guard or they would sort of be
against the military but they are made
up they have a significant former
military presence how do they conceive
of that of the idea that ultimately the
force that might stop them is the one
that many of them were once a part of
right and that's something you can't
escape
when i talk to
militia members and leaders about that
often they kind of deflect at first
but
when i press them they admit yes i mean
that you can't talk about fighting the
government without the possibility
um and really the almost probability if
you fight the government that your guns
are going to be pointed at law
enforcement
and or
troops
now what they'll say if you press them
is that you know righteous righteous
troops and law enforcement will step
aside because the battle will be
righteous for the militia guys but it's
absolutely something that hangs in the
background and you can't avoid it and
when you look at those standoffs
they were against law enforcement and
they weren't against troops but they
were against law enforcement and in the
case of the oregon standoff you know
there was a deadly deadly shootout um
and a man got killed so it's not it's
not theoretical that could happen and it
has happened in terms of the political
alignment
when it comes to
democrats republicans etc i mean you
made it clear they want to move the
government to the right their most
important issues certainly align more
with the republican party than the
democratic party but like is there any
political diversity within these groups
yeah and i also get into that in the
podcast because i i think the political
angle on these groups it makes them so
much more interesting now i mean i
should say yes and no uh are any of them
democrats that i've met no
um do they have diverse political views
yeah yeah yeah there there is a
diversity of views some are more
libertarian sort of live and let live
some of them are really much more sort
of fundamentalist far right groups and i
would say more of them are are of that
ilk um and that's why they're targeting
school boards they talk a lot about
critical race theory and culture war
issues
and i think that's a big change from the
1990s in the 1990s they might have been
very conservative but they were very
much pox on both parties they're all the
same
these guys today they're much more
involved in republican politics and i
think that's a really important shift
because they've sort of picked sides in
a way
that they didn't in the past they just
saw all government as bad before right
that that's interesting and there's also
the question as to
how responsible donald trump is for that
and whether the political activism may
fade to some degree if trumpism fades i
mean that's a question we've had about
the general voter who never voted before
trump was pulled in to vote for trump
and then now
it's unclear how engaged they stay right
yeah and i think i think that's the the
one of the biggest questions hanging
over this movement now i think they were
on the rise before trump
i saw them rising before trump but they
were they were super charged by trump
they saw somebody at the highest echelon
of power
um really they saw him as supportive now
they talk a lot about basically taking
that momentum and continuing
that kind of trumpism without trump
um i think we're gonna see i think i
think that's that's a real open question
i think these midterm elections might
have a lot to do with it
um but they're trying to keep that
momentum up right now
and i i do think we'll see if trump
jumps back in 2024 but without him they
do potentially lose momentum
um but i guess we'll just have to see
how far right um the right wing of
american politics has gone
without a doubt yeah no that's it's
without a doubt an open question that
we're all sort of anxiously waiting
waiting to start getting some answers to
uh the podcast is extremely american
creator and host of the podcast heath
drewsen has been uh talking to us about
his investigative work heath really
appreciate your time today
thanks so much i appreciate you having
me on